yeah let's see okay let's play deform so
that at least know something about this
the missing link do I know the sky very
long religious texts but it doesn't have
the name in them it's from the
Netherlands right here huh okay III the
Rubenstein let's see what is going for
v3 I b6 let some transpose into that the
damage okay I don't mind to have this in
one move and third the knight on f3 this
is some this is quite a sharp position
now interesting yeah okay um how to play
this now maybe take only things and play
95 it's am here you need to be really
really quick you somehow lose the tempo
anything then the whole momentum is
wrecked and you're just worse g5 and no
II five was my idea f5 age six and mmm
and it takes d6
what about f5 Queen h5 first and then e
5 is also interesting yeah okay I need
to need to play in this at some point
age six and then e five sauce my plan
ok
Bishop's seek to with this completely
ridiculous Bishop see two tanks I cannot
take the bishop I had the night and if
he takes I can also get this chick first
check first and then Bishop c2 yeah this
is so maybe night am now queen just
excessive that Bishop f1 Queen g6 is
some twinning and that's night f7
threatens yeah Bishop g6 now with the
temple and then I can move the rook rook
f3 to h3 for instance but maybe they're
even even more powerful do I need to
meet look let's say Queenie 7 and I go
f5 as this looks really powerful at five
not sure if it is working but looks like
a powerful move f5 Bishop f1 and then
and then something f6 or something
progress is nonsense and I should really
just play work f 3 i'll wait wait wait i
could also think about taking on d6 why
not and the Queen has to take and then
look the one with the temple yeah this
is this is good simple and good
my ideas anyway f5 f5 and then sacrifice
here on h6 maybe 9400 f5 all night f75
takes 94 f for Bishop h6 this is this
the way to go
hmm this is really what can can really
know this really
yeah okay
this looks this looks like like a
disaster yeah I don't see it don't see
any kind of move check here this this is
I planned this I'd planned this and this
looks looks simple and good oh forgot
about that okay I don't have c4 I wanted
to play c4 was silly very silly hmm
don't tell me this position isn't isn't
so clear anymore unbelievable
yeah I'm not 20 seconds can you believe
that What nonsense I'll probably made
somewhere
I cannot really tell what this position
is 20 seconds I'm warning maybe it is
too good for our white but certainly not
as good as it was
och g6 at least let's a thread
rookie 7 nesmith right now
check
under year 10 is threatening a meaty I
cannot believe this [ __ ] really
unbelievable
check
check
check check check check check check
check why do ah no comment absolutely no
comment on this game what the hell what
the hell ok yeah ok yeah well I want to
see where I could have could have
finished this nonsense much earlier
because it was certainly made or
something like like here yeah 96 is the
other move I assembly wasn't so sure if
there is some some sort of trick I mean
Knight f6 or something but this is
probably not working and this is just
plus 6 cm ok what I played is also
winning yeah but not so clear problem
yeah this isn't it when I can't believe
this unbelievable ya da black is better
ok yeah yeah this is a draw funny enough
the computer says and this wins for
white queen d 5 wins oh ok I had seven
seconds so this was he was just just
blundering this now yeah yeah of course
yeah and yeah yeah okay no use in
analyzing this is two seconds yeah I was
getting close actually I shouldn't ever
didn't blunder the Queen Helen oh
alright thanks for watching